jeff bezos is the single richest person
in modern history
and his company amazon.com is the second
company to have reached a one
trillion dollar market cap he went from
being the son of a 17 year old high
school student and cuban immigrant
stepfather
to now having a net worth of over 143
billion dollars and today we're going to
learn his best advice
on how you can focus on your customers
rise and shine it's espresso time
i wake up every morning
hey it's evan carmichael and every
morning i give you a shot of espresso to
help you believe in yourself more
and start your day with confidence so
good morning
i believe in you and let's do this jeff
bezos tell us how to focus on our
customers
when you buy over the internet amazon do
you ever
get the wrong order is anything ever
wrong what do you do do you call up and
complain or you don't have any problems
no i
i i i'm a customer of amazon hopefully
like all of you in this is there one
person full time your service is your
account
even this room is not an amazon customer
see me right afterwards and i'll um i'll
walk you through it
it's um i i yeah i get i have problems
sometimes um
and i and i treat them like the same way
i treat
a problem that i would get from customer
my email address is famous
and i keep it and i read it it's jeff at
amazon.com i don't see every email that
i get anymore because i get too many
but i see a lot of them and i use my
curiosity
to pick out certain emails i'll get one
from a customer and
there's a defect you know we've done
something wrong that's the usually
people are writing us
not always but usually the writing is
because we've screwed up their order
somehow
and i am so i look at this and for some
reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study
and and find real root cause or causes
it's usually causes
real root causes and then real root
fixes
so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer
and that process is um a gigantic part
of what we do
so i would treat my if i have a failed
order or some bad customer experience i
would treat it just like that
most entrepreneurs are too afraid to
have honest conversations with their
customers
and ultimately it leads to their failure
you're afraid of negative comments
you're afraid of disappointing people
you're afraid of what they are going to
say about you but being afraid is not a
good enough reason
not anymore it leaves you playing small
knowing that you can do more
by keeping your foot on your break if
you're afraid
you solve it by jumping in not avoiding
it and guess what
you do scary things so for a while now
i've had
a couple people on my team who helped me
respond to all the comments and
emails and inboxes and it's it's it's an
amazing
problem to have it's amazing opportunity
to have so many people care about the
work that i'm creating
and i thought it was important that we
respond to every comment i thought
every comment on that goes on this video
every comment that goes on all of my
channels and all my videos
i want them to have a response i think
what a lot of youtubers do
is they create content and then they
never respond at the beginning they do
at the beginning you do
but then it becomes too time consuming
then you spend more time responding to
comments and you do actually making
content
and it becomes overwhelming and what a
lot of people fail to do
is then just delegate it it's like if
somebody comes into your store
you want somebody to talk to the person
doesn't mean it has to be you all the
time but somebody should talk to the
customer and
see how they're doing and ask them if
they have you know questions or help
and so i think that just translates into
youtube comments and instagram comments
and and responding to email and so for
the past number of years i've had
somebody help me manage
the community and respond to your
comments and they put their name at the
end
um because i don't want you thinking
it's coming directly from me
but what i always give instructions for
is
if it's a negative comment i want to see
it if it's feedback i want to see it if
somebody's just saying evan great
message
somebody's just giving a thumbs up or or
a heart emoji
awesome i love it i appreciate you i
don't need to see all those
i love the good news it's amazing and i
always check every day to see what's
kind of going on
but i don't see every positive comment i
want to see all the negative ones
i want to see all the feedback i want to
see the hate i want to see
the constructive feedback a lot of times
it's something you can learn
inside of the negative feedback even if
they're coming at you with negativity
and hatred
and just nastiness maybe there's
something inside that comma that you can
still learn from and so
we use a software program called
legorepulse and
um my main guy right now belko is going
through and getting all the comments
and he's responding to a lot and he's
such a force for good and he's he's
cheering people on and giving them love
and support
and anytime there's a negative comment
or feedback i say flag it for me
and i go into agora pulse every day and
i look at the fly comments first
before i get to the general comments the
flag comments that say
what what needs fixing what are people
upset about what didn't they like
who did i profile that people are
getting you know upset on
and a lot of times um there's nothing we
can really do about it
but sometimes there is and it's great
feedback
and those should be the people that you
want to hear
most entrepreneurs do the opposite you
want to hear all the good news and the
accolades and how much you're winning
and amazing
and you want to either not hear the
negative feedback or pretend it didn't
exist
or just cut off access so that you don't
see it and don't hear and people just
leave upset and angry
and by no means are we perfect by no
means is everybody
always then happy with what i'm doing
for sure but it's always my intention
that i want to be able to listen to the
negative feedback and the criticism
and design systems around it and so
being willing to have an honest
conversation with your customers your
team
your people your your husband your wife
your kids your parents
right like that's how you get better
that's how you build better
relationships period
whether it's business relationships or
any personal relationship in your life
having the ability to have an honest
conversation and be
able to receive honest feedback even if
it hurts
even if somebody's telling you that you
suck even if it's not legitimate
even if it if it's tearing at your
inners that ability to have the presence
of mind to be open to the feedback
and not immediately taking it personal
and reacting
so you can actually learn from it and
get better i think is a valuable skill
that will serve you for life
so i've got a three-step process that i
use that i follow and how we take in
negative feedback
that i think will help as well as reduce
your barriers to be able to do it but
before that if you want to have more
confidence self love and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
where i send you an email every day
to shift your confidence forward they're
free the links to join on the
description below
the stress primarily comes from not
taking action if everything has to work
in two to three years
then that limits what you can do okay my
three-step process to getting feedback
to getting the truth from people and not
taking it personally myself let's do it
step number one
is pay attention to the feedback
especially the worst like i talked about
of how we do it with our comments and
social media using a tool like a gore
pulse
you want the negative feedback if you're
doing everything yourself you're gonna
see everything yourself awesome
but if you have a team even a part-time
team who's managing some of the
customer-facing things for you
you tell them i want the negative
feedback somebody's complaining
i want to know somebody's upset i want
to know somebody didn't get their
product on time or is upset that we did
that i want to know tell me
somebody is negative nasty i want to
know i had one comment
somebody was so nasty somebody was just
so nasty in the comments and
fortunately we have such a great
community you guys are amazing if you
look at the comment section of my videos
versus so many other channels
you guys are are fantastic we've built a
pretty special community here
on all of the channels in believe nation
that that
i mean is amazing but you still will get
the odd person who comes in
who's not part of the culture who just
spews hate and it's probably because
they just had a bad day or they're
in a really nasty spot in their life
right now but they take it out on
your video on my video so we had one
really nasty comment
and uh velco responded in a in a
sarcastic way
and and i saw it and he never responds
in a sarcastic way
and i said hey if you see a comment like
this just give it to me
if you're getting emotionally caught up
in a negative way if you feel any kind
of stress bubbling up about this person
who's leaving this comment
i'll leave that all day assign it to me
i want the hardest ones
i want the nastiest ones i want the most
negative ones don't worry about it
don't don't let it stress you out go
give love
and give those ones to me you want the
negative feedback
step number two is use this phrase tell
me why i
suck this is one of my favorite things
to do whenever i'm around people who i
think i can learn from
i'll say tell me why i suck tell me why
i suck tell me why i'm the stupidest
person alive right now
why sounds crazy because i want the
honest feedback
so if i look at you know i go to youtube
events
and and i often my channel is being used
as one of the best practices
but i'm going with the mindset of i suck
i need to get better i'm here to learn
somebody here has something that they
can teach me
and so even if i feel like i have all
all the answers for a lot of things i
know that i don't
and so if i'm talking to somebody who
may have something to tell me
i may learn something from tell me why i
suck
because what they're gonna say almost
always is well you don't suck dude you
don't suck
but boom boom boom boom right and they
and say they have three ideas for you
if they don't know you that well they're
gonna couch
their opinions they're not gonna tell
you the full truth they're going to tell
you one of the three ideas and it's
probably the safest of the three ideas
they're going to tell you if i look at
my youtube channel they're going to tell
you you know
your titles could be better they're not
going to tell you well you suck on
camera
because that hurts because they don't
know you because we're afraid to hurt
people's feelings
so if you lead with tell me why i suck
it gives them permission to be honest
which is what you want
you want the real truth now you got to
be able to eat it and not be defensive
and say no i think i'm great
right thank you i super appreciate you
you walk into that room you walk into
that conversation with the expectation
of i
want to be beat up because they're not
beating me down
they're actually lifting me up with
great feedback
so you go in with the tell me why i suck
when you're ever around somebody who has
something to teach you
and then step number three is over
deliver like crazy
almost every situation with a customer
receivable
if you go back and make it up to them
the intention for you wasn't to screw
them over right if you made a mistake
with a customer
you build them double your product never
showed up
whatever it is you said something that
was offensive that you didn't mean to
right like you're not in business
to try to screw people over right if you
worry you're
probably not part of this community so
your desire is to help right you're
built to serve you want to help you're
trying to serve people you're going to
make
tons of mistakes on that journey so many
mistakes
i think every situation is savable if
you just show the heart
show the effort and over deliver like
crazy some of my my best customers
my best connections my best
relationships came out of
somebody feeling like i didn't do a good
enough job like i
not that i intentionally screwed them
over but that
they just didn't get a result and that
destroys me so much that
i over deliver so that then they wanna
they just love us
um i'm mentoring jeremy right now who
has a youtube business and grew to you
know six figures inside of one year
to help people build their youtube
channels consulting
and he had one client who um
wasn't happy wasn't wasn't doing the
work
wasn't getting the results blame jeremy
for everything blame me for everything
writes an email said she's gonna sue
everybody
uh charlatans and just rip off and
and copied her lawyer in and like expect
to go to court
jeremy's freaking out never seen
anything like this before i said dude
don't worry this is this is totally
savorable
this is totally savable this is not a
big problem now if you just leave it
alone it's a giant problem
right the last thing i do is deal with
somebody's lawyer especially u.s lawyers
they're very i'm canadian very litigious
um but this is totally savable dude this
is totally savable
and let's just make it up to her what
does she need
how do we solve this for her right and
we did
and and part of it was given um giving
her
she asked for the last you know month
refund where nothing was happening we
gave her an even bigger refund than what
she was asking for
um gave her more help on the channel
what she should do next and give her
road map
offered to help promote her new book uh
when it comes out
giving her an interview you know there's
lots of things
um that i wrote back in an email and
then she wrote back to say you know what
i'm sorry
i kind of freaked out i've i've been
screwed over by other people before
and now she said my default is i just
lawyer up
whenever there's anything even i just
lawyer up that's her default now
think of why she's acting she's been
screwed over so many times but now this
is her process
and and now it's great you know that now
i mean she's not an ongoing client
because she hasn't committed to you know
her youtube channel but but
there's no hard feelings right if
anything it's left a better taste in her
mouth
and so it's solvable from somebody who's
going to sue you and thinks you're a
ripoff artist in a charlatan
to now somebody who uh has referred some
business has has saying
you know good things i think almost
everything is solvable
if you have the right intent and you
over deliver like crazy
now i've got a special bonus script that
i think you're going to enjoy but before
that question of the day i want to know
who can you go to
and ask your feedback and say tell me
why i suck who are you going to ask for
feedback from let me know put it down in
the comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching and you
promise you commit that you're gonna do
something about it we take action here
in believe nation
you're promising to take action in your
life today based off of what you learned
here in this video
i want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe down the comments as
well
we've got a lot of work to do because
we've got
a lot of service centers and charge
stations
to construct so mostly it's like we're
trying to build
our service and charge infrastructure as
fast as possible
and i know this like some of the
customers who have ordered a car
they're not in the major cities so
they're a little unhappy with us because
we are delaying delivery of their car
and in fact i'm going to apologize to
some of them personally
to explain the reason we are delaying
deliveries because it's
we really want them to have a good
experience but if they're too far from a
service center
and and the charging is not sorted out
then they will not have a good
experience
um so we're going to delay their cars
just for a few months to make sure that
they have a good experience
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it it's right there next to me go
click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there